Also, since we're no longer doing cheek swab testing,
how do I know if I still have mold or Candida issues?
There's a lab through great claims laboratory
called the Micotox profile.
It's a really good lab that shows mold
and the different types of mold
that a person could have in their body.
So that's a great test to run.
And that will change over time.
So as you treat that one mold,
then you could run the testing in
and you could see the change.
You would see that in people,
time to time again.
So that's a test that you can run.
You can really know a lot by your symptoms too.
If you know you have a history of mold or Candida problems,
you still have symptoms probably
could still have pretty good chances still there.
So it's not always a need to do expensive testing.
So you have to use your deductive reasoning sense
and put on your Sherlock Holmes hat a little bit
and go, okay, well, this is still going on
and kind of dig to how you could better your situation.
Also, my husband bought a spooky two right machine.
I'm wondering if I could use that to detox the mold and Candida.
I'm not a specialist in spooky two
or not a fan of spooky two,
but certainly it could be a tool that could be beneficial.
So contact spooky two, see if they have programming
from mold and Candida.
Certainly you have a tool you should use it.